your ceo said on the 29th of november i
think it was that uh the your current
vaccine may have may be less effective
against the new omicron variant have you
seen any evidence since then to change
your mind on that
ian good morning thanks so much for
having me um look i think what we've
seen now from all sorts of pieces of
data from around the world is that
certainly all of the vaccines against uh
kovid
lose some degree of protection and
neutralization against
it's not surprising 51 different amino
acids we know about this
30 different amino acids in the in the
spike protein alone which is what these
antibodies bind to
what i think we're seeing and i think in
coming hours today tomorrow
and we'll see more data coming out from
modena
is that while if you've had the primary
vaccination and you're maybe three to
four months out from that there is a
waning of immunity and a waning of
protection
for people who have been boosted
and in those then coming weeks after
being boosted
immunity goes back up and there's a
decent degree of protection we've seen
that from some published data so i think
um you know we can be confident that
getting a boost of this vaccine will
continue to provide protection against
overcome but we need to be cautious and
obviously take things very carefully
what specific is data are you looking
for before you can be certain on that so
the gold standard data you know that we
look for and there's some come out from
the united kingdom from nick andrews is
to look at vaccine effectiveness now we
found with the modern vaccine all
throughout the pandemic that we have
excellent vaccine effectiveness
protection against infection protection
against hospitalization
and that is true and indeed death and
that's true overall and with delta
we because omicron is relatively new
although many hundreds of thousands of
people around the world are now getting
infected we don't really have that
degree of
confidence in data yet so we have to
rely on laboratory tests and our
colleagues around the world moderna and
researcher are doing those experiments
now and generally what they show
is that there is a
sometimes a 40-fold reduction in
immunity
people who are
three to six months out from their
initial vaccination
in those people who got the boost
and for moderna that could be a 50
microgram uh shop it could be 100
microgram shot their antibodies quickly
rise again
and we've seen that with the other
vaccines as well and there's protection
so i think the you know this is this is
generally good news
a lot of people have been making claims
encounter claims against how dangerous
this new particular new variant is what
is your view on that
i think it's a serious variant um
you know when you think about the fact
that
people who typically get infected with
delta
are usually not re-infected
that's not true with omicron data from
south africa have shown that it can
reinfect people
has a doubling time that's very fast
maybe three days typically we would see
doubling times of seven to fourteen days
look at the rising cases that we've seen
in numerous countries around the world
and data from denmark seems to say that
while it's early days
the rate of hospitalization for people
with omicron is about the same as
they've seen with hospitalization for
delta
so
this is a variant that is again what you
know people refer to as a fit virus
and it's coming into countries and
regions
on a background a very high delta
infection so the two together i think
make it a significant concern
on the basis of what you've just told me
then do you think that the recent
actions of the uk government are
proportionate
i think you know the issue with omicron
is that we've seen
already cases um
you know again in denmark higher than we
saw at the peak of the pandemic
uh
south africa
uh 250 cases a day maybe a month ago
now 23 25 000 cases a day
this is a
virus that's
proliferating and infecting people at a
high rate so
i think yes we need to be cautious we
need to take simple measures
masks hand washing
distancing
you know that coupled with immunization
and boosting i think can really protect
people in these coming winter months
now if you conclude that a new vaccine
is going to be required against this
particular variant or even a very
specific booster how rapidly do you
think you could turn that around
so we announced in early uh in this next
wave of the pandemic
that we were at risk as many other
manufacturers did at risk making a new
omicron specific variant that works on
going i think in the early new year uh
colleagues will be able to begin testing
that
in you know people around the world
uh it's probably then a three month two
month wait by time you've given the
vaccine to people
take some blood are they making
antibodies do those antibodies
neutralize so we're probably looking at
a lot of activity in the first quarter
of 2020 102
and then hopefully more results early q2
22.
and briefly if you were pleased paul
obviously modena has just signed a deal
with the uk government to supply another
60 million doses of the existing vaccine
if the new if the vaccine doesn't prove
to be as effective against omicron are
there any clauses in in that deal that
uh enable the government to get out of
it
you know i i think about just the
science and the medicine and i don't
know the specifics of the deals but
uh you know i can
definitely check into that i think the
the key here is that we've had a
tremendous partnership with the uk
jcvi vaccine task force
um and you know to bring or already the
moderna
vaccine to uk i think given the data
that we have
uh it really should offer a good degree
of protection and as i say we're working
on the next versions of the vaccine
that's needed
okay paul burton greatly appreciate you
speaking to me this morning thank you
thank you